well how about we talk about some real
news oh yeah terrible man yeah but we
got to talk about it yeah let's talk
about it yeah I can't breathe man dies
after pleading with officer attempting
to detain him in Minneapolis so it
sounds awfully familiar
yeah and this happened this happens but
there's a lot we got a breakthrough in
talking about this story for sure you
know what we saw was horrible completely
and utterly messed up Mayor Jacob Frei
set of video of the incident I believe
what I saw and what I saw was wrong at
every level this story I'm not gonna
show the video because I don't think we
can but to put it simply boesky the
quick gist you know and I was just
saying I wanted to believe that racism
was dying out you know that I don't see
it I have a lot of friends that are of
all ethnicities and then I see this and
it's like come on why is this racism
because it's a bunch of white cops
kneeling on his neck because they're
probably afraid because of the
mainstream media putting it out there
that oh it's black men are bad black man
or bad it's like and and that's what
they go for that's a big leap man you
know what it comes from being into New
York being in New York the New York City
police force are is the reason that I
I'm making this this jump because I've
seen it in New York so many times I
lived I lived in New York for 16 years
over there for a long time non-stop was
where these stories showing up all the
time all the time and I never saw a
white kid a white guy getting you know
killed getting getting you know thrown
in prison for no reason that's wolf man
there's a lot to dig through on that one
yeah yeah because here's what I mean but
this is just my first initial reaction
of seeing this it's like okay and they
don't they're not going to jail they're
just got fired yeah so this guy's
getting arrested here's the gist this
guy's this guy was uh there was a report
of a forgery in progress
this guy's apparently sending his car
cops come a forgery a forgery like
making a fake ID or something I guess so
they pull the guy out and apparently
according to them I don't know this is
true
they said he was resisting okay so they
put him on the ground a guy kneels on
his neck the guys are saying help I
can't breathe please please please I
can't breathe my stomach hurts my neck
hurts
I can't breathe and people are saying
like you
get off and get off them dude Neal's on
him for eight minutes dude on the ground
dies and then look at this look at this
headline though
check us out just a regular man they
don't they don't include black man
because that would make them look bad
and that's exactly what I'm talking
about they they can't do that because
it's just a regular man now that died we
don't want people to spread it around
that it was a black man that had died
but this and this is the that's a really
good point I don't know if I agree with
the reasoning but you brought up
something really really important look
at it why did the other story exact
white woman some Nothing story well so
let's go to live give context for those
that didn't hear earlier we're talking
about the woman in Central Park it's a
white woman and a black man arguing
about a dog on a leash Marin and the
news reports are like a white woman did
this to a black man or whatever now we
have an actual story about white cops
and a dear let's showing like man dying
check us out here's here's here's what
we were talking about but it's very
clear white woman on video calling on
one on a black man it's like okay Wow
alright really lay it out there I don't
know which one it is with this one and
then here we go the man actually dies
but they're trying to omit that he was
black because that would make it more
like obvious that I mean they're
obviously trying to hide I think they're
trying to down downplay it like you know
whoa the cops got fired it was just a
man that died men die all the time it's
a regular it's a regular thing yeah and
they're trying to avoid it and so let's
let's let's go let's go back to the New
York thing cuz this is important for a
lot of people who don't live in New York
New York is racist absolutely really
racist Brown let me tell you man at the
New York Bloomberg is on camera reported
where he was like I'm not even repeat
what the dude said he was like while we
have to send the police here because
those are the people who do it and it's
obviously these people and it's like
yeah I was about it was about stop and
frisk right and basically he was
pinpointing a certain minority group you
know what I can't stand openly and it's
amazingly terrible the woke sjw stuff
are people who can't see past race the
Michael Bloomberg stop and frisk tough
are the people can't see who can't see
past race yep so true both of them just
make everything worse you know you're
trying to actually address these
problems so but it's an older generation
and that's kind of what I was alluding
to before it is dying out it is a dying
breed in this world I
the sjw's are on the rise all of this
talk of race and everything has been
exploding no no no no no no it's because
they're all using the internet now so
they all have a voice and they're
screaming at the top of their lungs on
the internet it's it's the news they all
have access instances of the words like
critical race Theory diversity and
inclusion social justice racism bigotry
right are up like 10,000 percent in the
past 10 years right because they are in
time because they know those angry women
are gonna be sharing it it's not the
people like you and me that don't aren't
gonna be sharing this stuff we're gonna
be ragging on it being like look at this
crap know that this is what exactly
people share so there was at one point a
top ranked event does my for 400 global
top site that only did put up please
fertility right and like they wanted the
clips right because because people do
share it they go oh look at this oh look
at this and so this is what I wanted to
get to right I the way I see it is I'm
not I'm not gonna play the racism game
in this instance it's an individual and
if we approach all of these stories from
the perspective of an individual who had
basically like every single one of their
god-given rights violated right in this
regard even if you're a criminal man
like to have someone just reckless
disregard for your health pinning you
down so you can't breathe like the first
let me say if you're gonna if you're
gonna take somebody into custody you
know who are now responsible for their
well-being a hundred percent if you're
if you put him in a car and take him for
Nick you know Nichol riders I've heard
of it don't know they throw people in
the back of wagons or cars with no seat
belt and then shake the car around
that's Mel's nickel ride okay and so
that was actually what happened in
Baltic maybe what maybe what happened in
Baltimore I'm sure there's been updates
and this it killed the guy he's slid
Ford hit his head busted his neck or
something in this instance what I would
say to people who are like social
justice activists I understand your
concerns about race and all that stuff
right but but but hold onto that and
let's talk about this man who had his
life taken from him yeah raisin okay
that's good that's a good point and race
aside and hold on hold on I'm not saying
get rid of it I'm saying put it put
attack in that talk about this man who
has just killed an innocent well I don't
say innocent but on absolutely not
deserving
100% absolutely may you no no no no I'm
walking that back innocent until proven
guilty yeah and as far as I can tell was
innocent he was killed
we'll stop right there then I'll say to
the Conservatives I want you to look at
this man
ignore the the woke arguments and the
anger and talk about the violation of
our civil rights yes if you commit a
crime the cops can't just kill you right
straight up and they are and I have been
raised absolutely and listen my
arguments people on the right would be I
know that it affects people of all races
bargman people on the left I understand
I've seen the cops in New York target
the black neighborhoods purposefully in
heirloom burg it's like it goes on
record for it exactly so what we need to
do is make sure that every single
individual has their civil liberties
guarded protected the Constitution is
upheld because that you target the roots
the grass roots of these and then as you
move up things improve so the easiest
way to explain it to everybody is like
listen man if you have ten people and
they're ten people who are innocent and
killed or like it was you know that may
be in the process of a crime never
proven guilty and the cop did something
that killed him right let's say eight of
them are black - and ones Latino and
ones white okay and so if we just focus
on each individual in each instance and
you rectify those in justices and hold
those people accountable
you will disproportionately help the
people the oppressed minorities but you
will also make sure you won't ignore the
in justices that target other races as
well it's basically like I look at it
like grass roots you know if you're only
mowing the top of the lawn the problem
is never getting you know pulled up if
you're only cutting the weed you're
leaving the roots there it just grows
back you know and so what I see what I
see happening with stories like this is
you know when I look at I'm like here's
what here's how we solve this man
innocent until proven guilty the police
have to be responsible for this man's
death
absolutely 100% they killed him I don't
want to I don't want to make it an issue
are people gonna argue with each other
about racial justice inequities or
whatever it's like I think we all agree
this guy's civil liberties were violated
yeah and it and especially it was non a
non-violent crime he forgery so here's
here's so here's the challenge base they
said he was resisting right right they
said he was resistant and they tried for
ten minutes to get him in the car but lo
so then they sat for ten
more minutes laying out on him instead
of just getting a bunch of them and
putting him in the back of the car after
that 10 minutes of you know fighting
shirt tagged him with resisting arrest
hey I don't know what you do you know I
could argue they could have tased him or
something but then sometimes tasers kill
people and it's like I I guess the
instance here for me is first and
foremost I'll always stress like I don't
know what happened before this video
I agree why I'm very cautious yeah like
for all we know this guy was like you
know the the whole can like flooring
cars in the air and jumping in this you
know poor cop knocked him down for all
we know this guy was got his hands up
and not resisting and the cop pushed him
around and bashed him I have no idea
yeah I actually have a little bit of an
update oh I just saw scroll past me real
fast there was a video that was released
to the earlier part of this um it looks
like he wasn't resisting arrest at all
and the restaurant owner from like
across the street was like I didn't see
anything I didn't it didn't look like he
was fighting back at all I got I really
don't know what happened there it's
apparently really quiet exchange if he
was hulking out I don't know so you
don't think he was resisting that's what
they said it didn't sound like that I
would I believe it look man I believe it
to him it's weird for me how it's like
you have social justice activists on the
left who are constantly complaining
about the police and it's there's like
it there's like a weird inversion they
hate the police but they want big
government and then you see like the
small government people and advocates
defending the police more often and look
I get it there's there subtleties within
these arguments at a macro level to me
I'm kind of like it doesn't always make
sense yeah I'm sure there's argument you
can put forward about you know loyalty
Authority you know community and things
like that but I'm a small government
freedom liberty minded person I'm much
more about being on a farm with a bunch
of hippies eating watermelon and if some
dude comes in under the authority of the
state starts telling me what I got to do
I'm gonna be a lie Constitution buddy
read it read it and weep you know I
don't care what your your political
orientation is I don't care
all they care about their civil
liberties straight up so look the the
story here and I think the big
difference between this and things like
Michael Brown and Freddie gray Trayvon
Martin yep we got a video guys
on the ground yeah yeah and it's like
you know if that cop just asked for help
and then took his head off his knee off
the guy's neck you know like I might not
have died yeah when you when you talk
about you know the arguments for these
other individuals we just don't know and
that's one of the biggest problems we'll
never know because the people who were
there died exactly yeah man it's like
you didn't need to put your knee on his
neck and I've been you could have sat on
on his his hands lower of the lower of
you know he's obviously handcuffed
that's a that's a technique they do yeah
Anthony on the neck well oh I've had I
said it obviously kills people so they
should not make that a technique that
they use like the you know the air to
the Eric garner video yeah the dude was
selling cigarettes so the guy comes up
and puts a miniature or whatever yeah
it's it you know what man it's
ridiculous it is a it is a very very
dangerous balance between security and
liberties yeah cuz I was talking about
this earlier you know you know they
tried doing bail reform in New York I
did hear about that yeah the general
idea they did do bail reformed and they
did and it was a disaster right as a
huge mess yeah and I'm like a lot of
conservatives as well as me I'm like I'm
not surprised right but I agree with the
sentiment the idea is if you're innocent
until proven guilty and a cop arrests
you
you can't lock someone up until they can
pay a bill like that's messed up you
know because what ends up happening is
you have innocent people who get
wrongfully arrested you know and then
they're like your bail is set is a at
$1,000 nobody has it so they go to jail
for you know a couple weeks or whatever
till they can get a trial or however
long it takes sometimes months sometimes
longer
now they lost their job now they've been
evicted landlord says don't know where
they went they're gone and then that's
it their life is completely destroyed
yep and even if they get you know get
out and the trial says oh we're so sorry
you got arrested that's too bad
turns out you were innocent sorry yeah
so the idea in New York was you got to
release them then the problem was they
actually had people they knew were
committing these crimes like they watch
him do it and they turn him loose then
like they would commit the crimes again
so it's like man this is why I would
never want to be involved in politics
yeah like that sets legit you
you know I think the issue is for big
cities mm-hmm they're big cities that's
it
cuz think about what life would be like
if you lived in middle of nowhere and
you had your second Amendment rights and
the the police department was erring on
the side of freedom so they were like if
you get caught committing a crime you
know innocent till proven guilty we're
gonna let you go then the neighbors
would be alike alright but I'm strapped
at home so if you try to mess with my
property to come and you know mess with
my family we're gonna defend ourselves
you know then people have the ability to
protect themselves the problem with New
York is you don't so when these
criminals get released then go rob
people again it's just like I guess I'll
just stand here and have this criminal
wreak havoc you can't have a count this
combination of things where you say
we're gonna pull the liberty of the
criminals but restrict the liberty of
the private citizens to prep them selves
that's that's the big problem and look
at this it even says right here video of
the incident shows that a white
Minneapolis police officer had a black
man pinned to the ground with his knee
so that so they switch it on you they're
like alright well now we'll give you the
facts now well now we're gonna give you
the nitty gritty of man and it says the
man looked like already dead before an
ambulance got there so it's like he even
said in the video like I can't breathe I
can't breathe so light light up on his
neck a little bit like what are you
doing wrong I I can't believe they just
got fired and that's it cops need to be
held accountable if they're gonna kill
people I think it's a murder I think
that's it cops should be able to a
higher standard even better I do they
need to be held to a higher standard for
some reasons they have the authority of
the state mm-hmm which which arms them
and it's that is not a license to kill
right and that's how they act so so well
there's a couple reasons why I think
they should be on to a higher standard
first and foremost in many of these
jurisdictions I do not like the idea
that the government has granted the
authority to bear arms and the people
aren't that to me is shockingly insane
indeed like we're gonna we're gonna only
people who are allowed to go be armed
are you know like agents of the state or
whatever no I'm not I'm not all about
that the other issue is they're a
representation of upholding the law
which means if they break the law well
shouldn't they like how are we gonna set
an example to everyone else that the law
matters if the people who are supposed
to uphold it often get a slap on the
wrist or they walk
like therein lies a real problem III do
recognize that the challenge right one
of the big challenges is that you have
cops who know that their job is
dangerous and are tasked with going and
doing dangerous things and so they might
panic or be scared but I was talking to
this NYPD detective and he was like man
the most dangerous thing in the world is
a scared person holding a gun like
obviously it's an exaggeration the most
dangerous person in the world spike Kim
Jungman scared and put his finger over
the newt button but you get the point so
he was like it's just a really really
big gun that's a lot of devastating
damage so the same thing if you've got
cops who are not trained properly not
you know mentally prepared for this and
they're scared like don't put a gun in
their hands you know what I mean that's
true like people got a head like it's
funny to me that there are I would I
would actually be willing to bet that
you know and I think this may be why the
to a is so strong in conservative
communities I'd be willing to bet the
average conservative in a rural district
is better trained with a firearm than
your average NYPD cop probably but
remember that store-bought NYPD cops
firing randomly and like hitting a bunch
of innocent people like eight people or
something that's that's what you get in
these cities man yeah because they're
not run properly they have a mishmash of
policy these things don't make sense
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
if you want to catch the full show tune
into this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you